welcome to this video that's a very
strong opponent cool with that this is
some Grandmaster Dimitri yaakov ankle is
a multiple player of the Russian
Olympiad team narrated about 2,700 2,700
50 or 60 was his best rating and he will
certainly know what to do against this
line self let's let's see what the top
player oh it's not playing c6 that's
interesting um yeah well this is also i
think an online and much sharper line
obviously h5 maybe okay let's just let's
just fire away here and see what happens
page six driving him back and then if
five maybe takes on c3 takes on f6 yeah
okay just that's just play as aggressive
as possible and see what happens
maybe this is the theoretical line and I
really had played it without knowing it
so I mean without knowing that it is a
line he's playing this really quickly
like he's seen it before amazing maybe
this is some some some line that has
been played yet it's not totally out of
the part of the question okay this pin
9075 has a bit a bit annoying should I
play Bishop e2 now maybe this is penises
it's not not very comfortable so he just
took it okay yeah well h6 this is a
debatable porn it can help with the text
them as it takes away an important
important square okay then it is getting
really weak take this but it can also be
weakness can be weakness the pawn and
also a strength so very controversial
position black seems to be okay they'll
really it does not have any problematic
pieces or on problems in a way I just
saw it that this is right when i moved i
thought okay queen h4n and with a double
attack mmm okay
okay well g3 I cannot even play can take
g3 now I cannot g3 Queen takes you far
okay but it's not it's not a totally
easy endgame please at least i hope i
have some some hope here with rugby 7
and most like that rabbit he can play
rugby head could claim
yeah and I have six seven you can play
of six this wasn't really a good there
may be f 6m se6 as a weakness
not sure he wants opposite colored
bishops only under more favorable
circumstances okay check here King g2 is
not may I have have this now
nice Cod rugby head I wonder about Roxy
one Bishop e3 this kind of idea already
can take them okay try it for the
opposite chirality bishops end game
which is still of course very favorable
for him but III is coming really quickly
and for Bishop f5 after the capture yeah
35 seconds so besides them pure the
problems associated with the pure
position there is the time I can give
the check now and play g3 or g3
immediately check ouch gets to mate who
gets to mate yeah very good game by
black I mean very tough of course I
overlooked Queen edge form maybe if I
address this probably it's not not so
terrible i have not terrible twosome
shouldn't be shouldn't be too negative
about this if I go if I go here I think
I'm okay don't think that this is a huge
problem or any my black black has a draw
like this of course but it's not oops
it's not like I mean I'm in huge trouble
but I was whatever he found curious how
quickly he played this like it's maybe a
really an online yeah and here i lost
the corn which yeah was obviously not
ideal this was this was a bad move
Bishop g5 but tough tough to defend the
problem is this is a very good setup the
bishop is safely blockading and they're
the age six phone here now is this more
of a weakness the computer is still
pretty optimistic about White's play
with Bishop e2 playing this yeah there
are chances to fight here Bishop e3 rook
see one I didn't defend it very well but
I was
down one time at the moment already yeah
and then going for this end game is
probably not a good idea this really
helped like this end game is lost here
Joe yeah I guess if you played just a
very clean game there is nothing nothing
to be done here nothing to be done so
while I could fight better after
blundering the pawn I must I must simply
knowledge the threat Queen hy I really
when I played Queen d3 I was seeing it
so I must play this this type of move
Black is not in bad shape though this
seems like a very viable line and I
don't know as far as i know this this
doesn't have the absolute best
reputation but ok i'm not really
claiming to be an ex good here here now
this looks totally normal really yeah we
should be too is probably also necessary
i don't think you can do without this in
the long run very tough very tough
alright thanks for watching